Once it was obvious that Lyft was going to be successful...
...and be able to do this peer-to-peer ride-sharing business,...
...he was savvy enough to launch his own products.
So Kalanick, well known as an extremely strong salesperson,...
...raised a huge amount of money.
They raised hundreds of millions from Google Ventures and TPG...
...and created Uber X,...
...which was really the defining product...
...which lets people sign up with basically the car they have...
...without having to have been this legacy black car worker.
Almost single-handedly, Kalanick created what we now call the gig economy,...
...paying independent contractors through an app for a service,...
...whether it's cleaning a home, delivering food or being a chauffeur.